nothing can break the bonds between one
of gameofthrones most memorable couples
Jason Momoa who played Cole Drogo on the
first season of the HBO fantasy drama
got emotional when discussing his
on-screen wife Amelia Clarke's health
battle that almost took her life twice
that the nearest Targaryen actress
revealed earlier this year as she had
previously suffered two brain aneurysms
the first of which came in 2011 just as
Game of Thrones was taking off speaking
with et at the game of Thrones Season 8
premiere in April the MOA praised
Clarke's courage and tenacity during the
hardest time in her life very sad she
almost lost her numerous times so I love
her to bits and she's here and she's
gonna do great things with it and teach
the world them in March of 2019 the
Clarke penned a moving essay for The New
Yorker in which she detailed that she
had experienced a brain aneurysm at the
age of 24 and then was stuck with a
brain bleed two years later or doctors
attempted to reduce the site of the
original aneurysm the actress opened up
about the emergency surgery she
underwent to seal off the aneurysm
Clarke then detailed the second
operation required to take care of the
expanding growth in her brain plus a
subsequent surgery needed when the
operation failed and left her with a
massive bleed she wrote the operation
lasted three hours when I woke the pain
was unbearable I had no idea where I was
my field of vision was constricted I
couldn't remember my name instead
nonsense words tumbled out of my mouth
when I went into a blind panic I'd never
experienced fear like that a sense of
doom closing in off a second and third
surgeries she wrote the recovery was
even more painful than there had been
after the first surgery I looked as
though I had been through a war more
gruesome than any that daenerys
experienced and there was above all a
constant worry about cognitive or
sensory losses would it be concentration
memory peripheral vision now I tell
people that what it robbed me off is
good taste in man in the midst of all
this hardship and a double brush of
death Clarke was actually filming Game
of Thrones as well as rehearsing for the
2013 Broadway rendition of Breakfast at
Tiffany's
though she kept her composure told
virtually no one about what she had been
through and even denied the genuinely
accurate reports that she had
experienced life-threatening trauma
Clarke was overwhelmed with exhaustion
and anxiety she wrote on the first day
of shooting for Game of Thrones season
two I kept telling myself I am fine I'm
in my 20s I'm fine
I threw myself into the work but after
that first day of filming I barely made
it back to the hotel before I collapsed
of exhaustion if I'm truly being honest
every minute of every day I thought I
was going to die but like the fireproof
mother of dragons she plays Clark was
resilient and determined and came out on
the other side with a renewed sense of
hope and purpose after bravely sharing
her story with the public Clark
announced that she had partnered with
executives in the United States and
United Kingdom to develop a charity
called same--you which works to provide
additional and more immediate
rehabilitation options for young people
who have suffered brain injuries as well
as to fund research advocate for policy
change and facilitate innovations and
specialists nurse training she's so
brave and then hoping the world in
trying to raise awareness six seasons
later Clark say she couldn't be more
grateful to have cheated death twice and
live to help bring Game of Thrones to
its epic conclusion she wrote there is
something gratifying and beyond lucky
about coming to the end of Thrones I'm
so happy to be here to see the end of
this story and the beginning of whatever
comes next
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]